okay good can I ask you what a very
guilty look on your face
what I think might be a sensitive
question perhaps a personal question did
you watch the premiere of powerslap yeah
okay and you're right that is a tough
one yeah where do you go on that and
maybe you could give me some guidance
um
no I did not but I feel as though I did
I I read all about it I saw the replays
and then uh surprisingly to me is
apparently they have competition there's
somebody else in Vegas uh doing a slap
League they they made it to TV about a
week before Dana did they were in a cage
I mean I thought it was Dana's Brother
Project but it's not
um and my only point is I didn't know
that there was room for two I didn't
know there's room for three I know there
was room for one
I want to be very open to it I really do
I've never seen a football game or a
hockey game I know it there but I've
never watched a full one and I would
like to have more hobbies and maybe that
slap is one of them so I have an open
mind but I don't know how they're going
to convince me there's a sport going on
if you let the person hit you right I'm
open to it but I think they're gonna
have a hard time they're gonna have a
hard time with me well it's weird
because like when you're watching UFC
one two three you're like oh [__] this
is going to be huge like you know it's
going to be huge and then I saw the TBS
commercial and you're like how is this
how why are they getting behind this
like how is how does this have legs
really really weird to me I I struggle
with it as well
um and and
I remember when jackass came out or when
it was gonna come out I remember
thinking yeah there there's uh
this is something that that would
resonate what we're doing it's wild it's
crazy I think I can picture it being
really popular the problem that I
envisioned us having is just being
allowed on TV sure you know like uh then
Nobody's Gonna Love nobody's gonna show
what we do we became rather Nimble in
working our way around the rules and
kind of jumping through hoops and a
little bit we found ways to get away
with showing what what we do
I don't know how this is on TV sure it's
not one of the same thing and you know
so it's already done everything that
we're seeing is already done they're
acting as though they're just presenting
this but it's in the can and I only
point that out because you know they've
got a live audience there or or even the
the officials that were overseeing are
those are the same guys that you see
overseeing the Octagon right you know
because it is the Nevada State athletic
Christmas they apply the officials and
there was just there was a lot of
support there that I I think is helpful
but I think it still does come down to
why are you guys why are you letting the
guy hit you why are you letting him hit
you right I've never driven around town
and seen a studio where it's how you
come in and sign up and I've never met a
guy that goes I'm a coach and I teach
people to slap by that just hasn't
you don't have that sacrifice to me I
don't I don't know that you're a sport
right the the point I was making before
about how I pictured jackass being
popular but I was having trouble getting
on TV
it
I I don't I I don't necessarily
feel like power slap is even like maybe
it is popular but there's something that
about like what what we did that was
kind of cute silly clever you know as
well as dangerous sure and but the slap
thing just doesn't feel like it's that
you know like I I love a great you know
wild and crazy thing and I I I struggle
with it I think it's good and short form
like like a nice Tick Tock clip with
somebody getting slapped and knocked out
but I don't think long form 30 minutes
yeah whenever I saw it before it was
always just looked like a backyard
wrestling operation yeah kid like like
it's guys that that that are doing it on
their own it's like oh what are they
doing but they're crazy and like they're
just kind of like you know in a uh
official capacity in a like regulated
format it it just it feels but I'm very
interested to see like how it performs
on a commercial level for sure and I
will tell you this I
censions and been more inundated whether
it was Clips online or the conversation
we're having now uh with slap than I
ever have been with bare knuckle just by
example okay bare knuckles got this
great production they're paying good
money they're bringing in uh very nice
crowds uh but I I belong to a gym I
belong to an MMA gym I've had teammates
Paige VanZant by example that's going to
do bare knuckle we're not in the sun
after practice talking about bare
knuckle fighting but everywhere I go
they are talking about slap and I don't
know you know how that translates if
that's a good thing it's a bad thing but
there seems to be something at least
ripe for the taking if Dana can grab
those stores and there is a story to
tell and he's a masterful Storyteller if
he can get us enveloped uh he's gonna
have something here but the action
itself that's not going to do it and I
think a cage fight does I think you
could watch a cage fight on mute and
understand what's going on I think we're
gonna need it we're gonna need a story
why are you guys here what brought us
here and why are we right why are we
doing this it's very well put do you
like shopping on Amazon I do and good
news is Stevo's butt wipes for your butt
hole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude